[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre madame la Première
ministre je pense qu'en ce moment nombre
de nos compatriotes se sentent autant
israéliens que Palestiniens et nous
sommes collectivement meurtris de la
situation au Proche Orient le Hamas et
ses atrocités du 7 octobre ont plongé
ces deux peuples dans un abîme sans fond
il devra en payer le prix le peuple
palestinien n'est pas le Hamas il est la
victime collatérale de cette
organisation
mais aujourd'hui ce sont des centaines
de milliers de femmes d'hommes et
surtout d'enfants qui sont privés de
toit d'électricité de nourriture d'eau
de soins et qui n'ont aucune possibilité
de
s'enfuir les accords de cette nuit
constitue le premier pas depuis 46 jours
vers une acalmie du conflit en échange
d'une libération encore trop partielle
de 50 otages par le Hamas l'État
d'Israël accepterait de de cesser pour 5
jourses les
opérations cet accord doit aussi et
c'est un point important permettre
d'intensifier l'aide humanitaire aux
civils
palestinien madame la Première ministre
pouvez-vous d'abord nous faire un point
sur la question des
otages peut-on considérer que cet accord
pourrait être un premier acte sur la
voie du cesser le feu d'autre part
comment la France peut-elle agir pour
venir en aide aux populations civiles en
danger et avec quel moyen opérationnel
enfin
quelle action diplomatique d'envergure
peuvent être mené le conflit
israélo-palestinien n'a que trop duré
comme l'a très bien dit mon collègue
bourlange président bourlange l'autre
jour il nous faut affirmer encore plus
haut et encore plus fort la nécessité
d'une solution à deux états où chacun
devra reconnaître les besoins légitimes
de l'autre je vous remercie